and you know what dogs is something i
don't think people really understand
enough about it's one of my obsessions
so
um they they my dad always used to say
though he go those things
those things are basically human and i
mean they dream
they have anxiety uh and what people
often overlook about dogs is without
dogs we wouldn't be here we would not
have ever evolved from hunter-gatherer
to agrarian to you know um
civilization we wouldn't have cities we
wouldn't have anything i mean
they are our partner in survival and
they are a magical animal there's no
there's no animal that was it was like
destiny almost i mean a malleable animal
there's no animal that's that malleable
that in a few generations you can tailor
to
a specific job that you need and without
that animal without dogs doing that
animal protecting our crops from
from uh you know uh scavengers and stuff
like that
you know the list goes on we wouldn't be
here
so we that's an often overlooked fact
that
human evolution was not uh done in a
vacuum just with humans i mean without
dogs we would have never evolved i mean
we weren't the apex predator for most of
our existence we weren't even the apex
predator i mean we're getting eaten by
hyenas which is my favorite animal
um and you know that's kind of an
injustice to i mean i'm kind of mad at
dogs die
we deserve to get eaten by hyenas but
without dogs we wouldn't be here
and dogs dogs deserve the protection so
do horses they lugged us around
for thousands of years and now these
german psychopaths are eating
them or whatever
we should not eat horse meat just on
like be a good dude man these things
lugged us around for generations they're
beautiful
you know ride them or i don't know i
don't know but
it rubs me the wrong way that we eat
horses yeah the horses one
is interesting and one of my favorite
books is animal farm by orwell and the
horses
don't get a good ending in that uh
i kind of uh my spirit animal i suppose
is the horse from animal farm
boxer where he says i will work harder
that's his motto
i i work really hard uh at stupid things
that's that's basically what i just hit
my head against the wall for no reason
whatsoever but that probably fulfills
you have a big brain you're probably
born with a big brain that kind of
fulfills
killing neurons it's exercise for you
yes yes
don't you think some animals deserve to
be eaten though kind of like hyenas
come on dude i mean they gotta respect
the hyena okay so let's look
first of all let me just comment on the
dog thing there is like conferences on
dog cognition
from a perspective of people that study
psychology cognitive science
neuroscience dogs are fascinating
the way they move their eyes they're
able to they're the only other animal
besides humans
they're able to communicate with their
eyes they can look at a thing
and look back at you and look back at
the thing to communicate that we're all
like
through our eyes communicate that we're
collaborating so uh every other animal
uses their eyes to actually look at
things
the dogs use it to like communicate with
you with us humans
it's fascinating there's a lot of other
elements of dogs that are amazing
yeah i mean if it wasn't for them
they're the ones they were our first
alarm system for predators they were
defenders i mean the basenji is one of
the most ancient dogs i mean they're
tiny but they're fearless yeah and they
would chase off lions like you know
there'd be packs of them and they chase
off lions and
protect the tribes it's it's it's i even
get tingles like thinking about dogs
because i have a dog i love my dog it's
just
and there's something about when you're
walking with your dog off leash in the
woods it like
there's something about it that's like
that that
tugs at that uh millions of years of
evolution like
that gut you know it's like i had a
finished friend of mine he's a comic
tommy valemis once told me he was like
uh he was like the gut
he's like i believe in the like that gut
you know when you have that feeling he's
like always trust that because that
is million those are all your ancestors
that's
the survival instinct of all your
ancestors at the beginning of time
you know telling you like hey
something's off here something's you
know so don't get in the car with ted
bundy is what i'm saying ladies how
stupid
who how could you fall for that you know
he's got a sling on don't get in
yeah follow the gut my question to you
are psychopaths
essentially robots so first of all let's
not you're using the word robot in a
derogatory way that i
feel i'm i'm i'm triggered by okay yeah
and you said i feel offended
you should be because you know what
people are always scared of robots but i
i actually uh i have i've made the sort
of uh
i i i've made it to say hey i've i
thought about it like rob
robots have been nothing but helpful
it's the people we should be scared of
right again we're kind of missing
the most destructive thing is us because
but robots
are helpful i mean this is a
robot you know i went on a hotel tonight
i'm already booked up you know i got my
i can change my flight if if this
barbecue with rogan goes 16 hours which
whatever rogan wants to do i'll do if he
wants to kick me in the chest i'll let
him kick me in the chest whatever
um robots are helpful no
yeah uh tanks and autonomous weapon
systems don't kill people people kill
people
yeah that's yeah the nra's about to
collect that for you
uh a lot of love for dogs i appreciate
it very much and at the same time
you have the other thing that people
seem to have love for which is cats
and on the flip side of everything
you've said
i'm trying to understand what have cats
ever done for human civilization
they keep rodents away the domesticated
cat is very important
keeps rodents away yeah that's what they
were domesticated for i mean they're
psychopathic killers who end up
killing uh innocent um neighborhood
chipmunks and yeah and birds uh they
really affect the uh
the balance of the local ecosystem but
if you have love for cats too not as
much as dogs i mean dogs are like you
said they look at humans i i actually
read an article there some people were
theorizing they're smarter than chimps
because
of the way they can work with humans and
there was one border collie that spoke
like
300 words like a quarter like a lang
almost
part of the language and their nose is
like a ma i mean that's like magic dude
if you can smell in my ass to what i had
for breakfast from
miles away that's intelligent that's
intelligence i mean in some ways that
their nose if you were to put it on a
scale maybe their nose is more
intelligent than our brain for what it
does you know it's like
i mean dude they can smell you from
miles away you ever see a dog just like
sniffing catching
i mean it's smelling like i don't
remember the the date on it but it's
like they have like millions of
receptors or something where we only
you know thank god we we don't have
their nose that would be that would make
sex weird
be a little too intense
you